In the previous video, we saw what a LAN is. You know, a network which can span
across a small region. Now imagine you
want to connect devices across multiple
cities or multiple continents.
Now, that's a huge network and that kind
of network is called WAN. In this, to
explain this,
let's take an example of an office
campus: you can have multiple buildings,
you know, multiple floors, you have
multiple computers in this different
floors. So, how do you connect them? You
take a router and put it in each floor
connect all the computers in in that
flow to the particular router and you
take a bigger router and you can all of
your router's to that and that's how you
can create a small WAN.